have a why
i'm here in orlando i'm here for one
more day and one of the things i
discovered on my trip here is i learned
about walt disney he's the king of
orlando here
and i looked at why did walt disney
start his company
what was the reason for creating walt
disney world this huge kingdom of
happiness here in orlando
and when he was talking about it he said
when he was younger he had two daughters
and saturday was daddy day saturday was
the day that
he got to take his daughters out i went
to a park or went to a playground or
whatever it was and he found that
most of the stuff available wasn't that
great and was only for kids
and his why the reason for creating walt
disney world
was he wanted a place where parents and
kids
could enjoy and have fun together
that was the guiding vision for walt
disney world and it's something that
everybody understands everybody can
relate to
and even though walt disney has passed
away
and even though a lot of the stuff that
you know he was working on may have
changed over the years
the new projects may have changed over
the years if you keep that simple vision
in mind that simple why in mind
it's easy to keep going it's easy for
people to understand it's even easy for
people to spread your message
so have a why what's your simple why why
do you do what you do it better be for
something more than money because if
it's just money
it's not going to work out you have to
have a simple
why for why you're doing your business
and let that guide
everything that you're doing with your
company believe
for those who watching like the video
give it a thumbs up below
leave a comment let me know what you
think make fun of my voice if you want
to today
and uh subscribe by clicking on my face
in the top corner
thank you so much i'll see you soon
you